So, the characteristic of ensemble learning is first this, that
you take a bunch of simple rules, all of which kind
of make sense and you can see as sort of helping.
But on their own, individually, do not give you a good
answer. And then you magically combine them in some way to
create a more complex rule, that in fact, works really well.
And ensemble learning algorithms have a sort of basic form to
them, that can be described in just one or two lines.
So let me do that and then we can start wondering a little bit
how we're going to make that real. So here's the basic form of an ensemble
learning algorithm. Basically you learn over a
subset of the data, and that generates
some kind of a rule. And then you learn over another subset of the data
and that generates a different rule. And then you learn over another subset of
the data and that generates yet a third rule, and yet a fourth rule, and
yet a fifth rule, and so on and so forth. And then eventually you
take all of those rules and you combine them into one of these complex rules.
So, we might imagine in the email case that I might
look at a small subset of email that I know is already
spam and discover that the word manly shows up in all of
them and therefore pick that up as a rule. That's going to be
good at that subset of mail, but not necessarily be good
at the other subset of mail. And do the same thing and
discover that a lot of the spam mails are in fact short
or a lot of them are just images or just urls and
so on and so forth. And that's how I
learn these rules by looking at different subsets. Which
is why you end up with rules that are very good at a small set of the data, but
aren't necessarily good at a large set of the
data. And then after you've collected these rules, you combine
them in some way, and there you go. And
that's really the beginning and the end of ensemble learning.
>> So wait. So, when you say manly was in a lot of the positive
examples. Do you mean like it distinguishes the
positive and the negative example? So it should
also not be in the negative examples.
>> That's right. That's exactly right. So think of
this as any other classification learning problem that you
would have where you're trying to come up with
some way to distinguish between the positives and the negatives.
>> And, and now why does it, why are we are looking at subsets of
the data? I don't understand why we can't just look at all, the whole data.
>> Well, if we look at all of the data,
then it's going to be hard to come up with these, these
simple rules. That's the basic answer. Actually, ask me that
question a little bit later, when we talk about overfitting,
and I think I'll have a good answer for you. Okay,
so here we go Michael. This is Ensemble Learning. You learn
over a subset of the data over and over again picking
up new rules and then you combine them and you're done.